[Music]
in crazy lilo News lilo and stitch
that's one thinking the other lilo oh
they call her lilo they used to back in
the freaking early 2000s where she was
relevant and in the tabloids all the
time
yeah [ __ ] burning her she's not even
here bro with the food she's relevant so
we're talking about right now yeah
that's true you wouldn't want to be
relevant for yeah damn Teddy Burton the
chef submitted by Punjabi Khaleesi
pooja be cuddly see that's right so like
a like an Indian Khaleesi
yeah lilo Lindsay Lohan made headlines
after being punched in her Instagram
story yeah why would you post it she
wanted it on there I bet she wanted it
my friend just told me that she broke up
with her ex on Instagram story and those
were her best numbers damn wait that's
like youtubers man youtubers get married
and divorced like for views wait you're
saying Lindsay Lohan broke up with her
ex no no no my friend Lizzie Lohan could
be my friend too that's what we're
[ __ ] up we gotta get divorced yes and
then back together you gotta do that we
broke up we are back together thing oh
dude you just gotta be boyfriend versus
girlfriend dude
yeah just they just love breaking up and
getting back together and then saying
why they're not together are they still
doing that I think so I know they've
always been separated but they're just
like they get together for like friends
[ __ ] like marathons or what okay but
don't they get to also get together it's
like it's like watching old videos of us
and they sit there and cry together need
to rejuvenate these videos and stuff
right um got busted for it but the thing
you gotta sign it up but I can't just be
like we broke up you got to be like you
got to leave like little hey
little things so that the face like Oh
was because of this right did you see
the way he said this in a JK video to
tip he said I like your hair himmat if
have something yeah his shoulder was
like stop yeah yeah and then it's like
oMG I feel so bad for her and you're the
one coming to get ya and then someone
else will be like no I saw her looking
at live there yeah we get to start some
[ __ ] drama dude I gotta spit
somebody's face that's old you been
doing that every time we switch seats
I'm taking these like oh they must be JK
drama it's not even crazy it's not or
like whenever I got a neck for Jo
she's totally [ __ ] Jo anyone that
sits I know that's true they said I was
[ __ ] doing yeah everyone you sit next
to Joe you're [ __ ] up yeah anyway
this episode david's but at least we all
know we're just sitting there she ain't
[ __ ] a minute
but most bars in this video that's a hot
iron skillet Lindsay Lohan she was on
Instagram live and she approached this
refugees refugees if they were on the
street and she was like telling her fans
look I wanna I want you guys to meet
these refugees I just met so I'm gonna
show you guys cutter in the face I'll
show you guys so she ends up going up to
them and she's trying to tell this
family cuz they're these two boys there
and she's trying to get these boys to
leave with her but then the families I
look they're just crazy so I start
walking away and then as they're walking
away you'll see in this video I'm I
should try to kidnap torture and take
them like as pets
I know right I want this one come with
me I like her dude she's proactive yeah
yeah she's really trying to make a
difference to leave an impact you know
and ruin this family's life go yes
so James II got this video then they
chopped it up really weirdly so that's
not my fault
here we go hey whose voices she sounds
like now she smokes a lot baked like
weird accent whoa is that a face
[Music]
tell me your story so I can help you
good job coming where's it at
they think it's a show there's like the
hairiest or he might be in Moscow is she
pretending that she can speak yeah this
is not Arab does live in Dubai you're
ruining our culture white dude at one
point
shallow enough what the hell you're
taking these children they want to go
what's with their accent I'm gonna jump
boys orange dude this is so funny I
can't stop thinking about it why that's
why I'm like I don't think she speaks
Farsi did she say don't [ __ ] with
Pakistan
Lindsay grassland of the boys and the
mom turned around and punched her in the
face and then she gave up she's like I
gotta save these kids and then she gets
mushed eventually nevermind the funny
thing is her self-righteous ass goes
over there but she becomes a predator
[ __ ] some families in [ __ ] I love the
[ __ ] the phlegm talk those like she
clearly doesn't speak the language it's
so good oh my god can't match it is so
rich some random stranger doesn't speak
your language just tries to take your
kid I know yeah but they're fellas good
virtue are we true yeah good point what
happened to Saudi Arabia was also
accusing them of self trafficking their
own children that's the reason why she
wouldn't leave them alone
she why did she picked up she just
walked by and she's like oh this is
trafficking yeah I don't know but she
used to protect Pakistan
oh I see so she thinks that the mom was
trying to pimp them out or something
something like that so she ends up
staying in the video something along the
lines of you should not have them on the
floor you should be a hard-working woman
you
be doing what you can what you can for
your children so they have a better life
tough talk is she she's a white girl
right yeah okay just make lindsay lohan
and yeah yeah never seen me alone i sing
but i'm just because she's doing all
this stuff and I'm like maybe she has
some kind of tie maybe she's like like
2% Saudi Arabian yeah oh she didn't
23andme yeah yeah
her real name is Lindsay Lohan Lohan
well known fact she's been more active
in the whole like Syrian refugee crisis
and like she's been trying but she she's
being active by shaming the victims and
she'll and then [ __ ] pretending to
speak their language that's so funny
like a sketch but she wasn't real it's
amazing this was a really well-written
sketch it heightens really Walter yeah
the give up was the best part dude you
remember when Madonna was doing a fake
London accent that's my favorite [ __ ]
man I just I love it some people you
know like for me if I'm talking to
someone too long I start picking up the
way that they talk that's pretty extreme
you could be but that's yeah I don't
think I've ever done a fake there's a
video where there's a video where a guy
hands Madonna flowers and then she like
Nick throws them away as he leaves and
she's like I love hydrangeas yeah man I
love these you guys want to see like the
worst progression of an accent look up
this girl named Mackenzie Dern she
fights in the UFC but she's like a BJJ
like champion her [ __ ] [ __ ] is so
hilarious onna she starts training with
Brazilian people she has a Portuguese
accent now I love it they did a
compilation video for years how would
you say goes hi I'm Mackenzie how are
you guys everything's great then also
she's like when I in the key and that
grab the person are you talking about
you [ __ ] weirdo I just feel like you
do become they become the average of the
five people you hang out with the most
you start absorbing the
you drop words not at the Lake United
mean thank you like my dad when he goes
to Hawaii he starts like speaking pidgin
dude was raised in cars but she'll say
[ __ ] like instead of say I'm hungry she
bit like I hunger you speak English dude
that's improper English it's not even
accent just went football stupid it is
contagious though because I even when I
go to Mexico and they're saying English
words but they don't understand yeah say
it the proper way right the way they say
it so they could understand what I'm
trying glitch but that makes sense
though that makes sense like if you go
to Japan and then you say karaoke
they're gonna be like what yeah so you
have to say it that way or or how do
they say it
how'd I'll get but then that's like the
same thing in Australian Australia right
you can't you if you say Mel born don't
be like what or they like all your soul
Q could smell been right but if you're
out here and you say to American they'll
be like yeah what are you saying it's
Mel born in Europe they say aluminum
instead of aluminium with aluminium you
have any aluminium foil no I don't have
a Lulu man on file
all right I do hate those people though
that have to like correct everybody all
the time
actually it's Brisbane yeah oh my
winning wrong [ __ ] in America everyone
says Brisbane so [ __ ] sorry
Korean crazy that all the time to me I'm
not Korean but I live in k-town and
they're just like you look Korean though
you're not Korean
no is it limo Korean last name your
Limerick Malaysian oh yeah that's right
you told me I've sung Chinese Malaysian
wait there are Koreans and k-town still
oh yeah they're Wow cuz when I lived
there it was just Mexican people
everywhere it's still mostly it is okay
yeah it's like Mexican always yell at me
for not knowing Spanish yeah I'm so I'm
not Mexican and they're like well you
look Mexican so you should be
it's always the older generation it's
your fault because you look Mexican
you caught them in their stupidity and
they just say [ __ ] blurted anything
out will you look back two kids so
speaking it's frustrated dude Nikki's
dad will be listened you know in his
garage he plays all kinds of [ __ ] right
he listens to like old records yes by
ac/dc and all that [ __ ] but then he we
get to like Hawaii or something he's
here and still jumps he's like enough
this is my music also bring some wrongs
and stuff he always wears beanies and
sweats at home but then it like Rams
beanies sweats but then he gets to
Hawaii he's wearing so wrongs and
getting like Kukui nuts
I wish there are ramps along strong I
picture her dad like biting into a mango
and going oh I need this for energy
that's why I can relate I'm like yeah
just like what's wrong with him I'll get
the story where's the bed I don't get it
why you're like all have a healing
waters of Hawaii the water and the
fruits there are like oh dude I agree
with that see there's something about
the air there's good yeah yeah you step
off the plane we should all go to Hawaii
we should leave David here know what you
can make that I'll take over for David
yeah you were just there you spoiled ass
yeah you're just there but I could go
again I'm not saying come again
[Music]